before the movie begins this story was
an anime that people actually liked but
also a narrative informs us that four
powerful Nations have ruled the planet
for ages they are fire air water and
Earth thought a century back the Fire
Nation deemed itself Superior and
declared a war against the other three
nations it now wants to conquer the
world alone the opening scene features a
boy named Soka and his younger sister
Katara who live in the southern water
tribe the place is completely covered in
snow and is encircled by icy waters
currently the siblings are trying to
hunt some animals for food after walking
a fair distance they stumble upon an
unusual Iceberg when they break into the
iceberg it releases a radiant beam of
light and reveals a 12 year old boy
named Aang he is a distinctive head
tattoo and a colossal flying companion
APPA realizing that the boy is exhausted
the siblings bring him back to their
Village on the other hand the beam of
light catches the attention of the
disgraced Prince of the Fire Nation Zuko
he has apparently been banished from the
kingdom for being too weak because of
this he is on a mission to find the
Avatar the only person who is capable of
bending all four elemental powers air
water Earth and fire it is the only way
Zuko can prove himself and restore his
honor allowing him to return back to his
family either that or he could buy a
really loud really big truck and drive
it around in the next scene Zuko along
with his men follow the beam of light
and arrive at the southern water tribe
to demand for the Avatar this leaves the
villagers who are mostly elderly in a
precarious position Katara despite being
young tries to use her water bending
skill to resist the Fire Nation but her
brother stops her faced with the threat
of harm to the villagers Aang willingly
surrenders himself to safeguard The
Village he is then taken away in their
ship where he meets Zuko's Uncle iro the
latter serves as a counterbalance to
Zuko's sharp tongue and impulsive anger
iro wants to check if Aang is the person
they are looking for so he decides to
conduct a test at first he places a
candle before Aang and this causes the
flame to ascend following this he pours
some water and this surprisingly takes a
circular shape of its own lastly when a
stone is presented to Aang iro develops
a strange bulge in his trousers but also
the stone balances vertically due to his
innate power these trials can confirmed
that the boy is indeed an avatar
meanwhile back in the Water Tribe Katara
confides in her brother emphasizing
their responsibility to protect Aang
they also talked to their grandmother
who identifies the boy's tattoo as an
avatars and urges them to rescue him
from the clutches of the Fire Nation
with this information in hand Soka and
Katara board APPA and embark on their
daring mission to rescue Aang on the
ship Zuko and iro decide to present Aang
to their Kingdom as a means to redeem
Zuko's lost honor hearing this an
enraged Aang uses his air-bending
abilities and incapacitates all the
guards in his path the siblings also
arrive there riding the flying beast and
rescue him following this the trio
travels to Aang's Homeland at the
southern air Temple upon arriving Aang
learns that he's been in the iceberg for
a century during which the Fire Nation
eradicated all other air Nomads
including his Guardian monk jayatso
overwhelmed by despair Ang enters the
Avatar State and traverses to the spirit
world where where he encounters a Dragon
Spirit however before he can take any
wrong steps katara's please snap the boy
out of it after this the group heads
towards an earth Kingdom Village to
check on the rest of the villagers upon
their arrival they discovered that the
village is under complete control of the
Fire Nation before long some soldiers
spot them and imprisoned them with the
rest of the earthbenders witnessing the
villagers subjected to enslavement Aang
delivers an inspiring
encouraging them to have faith in their
own abilities and utilize them to fight
for their freedom eventually the three
young Heroes managed to spark a
rebellion rallying the villagers to join
forces against the Fire Nation soldiers
through their Collective efforts they
ultimately emerge Victorious liberating
The Village from oppression in the
aftermath Ang tells Katara and Soka that
he is only mastered airbending and
remains untrained in the other three
Elemental disciplines he reveals that he
fled the monastery without training
because he wanted to live a normal life
according to Aang he was told that being
the Avatar requires immense sacrifice
including separation from family and all
other things that normal people have but
now that he recognizes his
responsibilities towards the Nations he
wants to master the remaining three
elemental powers with this unwavering
determination the trio sets off for the
northern water tribe where Aang can
learn from the water-bending Masters on
their way they make a brief stop by a
lake to spend the night shortly after
Aang decides to visit nearby Northern
Air Temple assuring the siblings that he
will return within a day once there Aang
meets with a peasant whom he initially
perceives as an ally however the
peasant's true Allegiance is soon
revealed he is a member of the Fire
Nation Aang is swiftly captured by
soldiers and presented to Zhao a
ruthless Fire Nation Commander not long
after a mysterious man with a blue demon
mask infiltrates the temple and fights
the guards to release Aang this masked
Marauder calls himself the blue Spirit
after learning about the Intruder
Commander Zhao dispatches his troops to
stop them but the blue spirit and Aang
joined forces to fend off the soldiers
when Commander Zhao declares an order to
not harm the Avatar the blue Spirit
immediately hold Zang at knife point to
secure their escape soon after Xiao
realizes that the blue spirit is none
other than Zuko in response he has his
crossbowmen incapacitate zuka with a
well-aimed bolt but before the soldiers
can apprehend them Aang uses his
abilities to escape with the uncle
conscious Zuko and watches over him
until the morning and then departs to
reunite with the siblings shortly after
Zuko regains Consciousness and makes his
way back to his uncle irel on the other
hand Commander Zhao conveys the news of
Zuko's intervention to the king he
explains that he had the Avatar captured
but Zuko came in the way and spoiled his
plans surprisingly the king doesn't get
angry and instructs the commander to
leave his son alone he believes that
Zuko is still naive so he doesn't
deserve punishment regardless Zhao who
is unable to tolerate Zuko on his way
attempts to kill him by blowing up the
entire ship fortunately Zuko somehow
manages to survive meanwhile Aang Soka
and Katara reach the northern water
tribe where they receive a warm welcome
from the inhabitants they present
themselves before the Royal Court where
Aang proves himself to be the last
airbender earning him permission to
undergo training with the master Aang is
then introduced to a water bending
master named paku who starts teaching
both Aang and Tara in the Advanced
Techniques of water bending including
the magic beer bong technique in the
midst of their training Soca and
Princess you of the northern water tribe
find themselves drawn to each other
seemingly experiencing love at first
sight apart from all this the kingdom
seems to be aware of the impending War
so they begin the preparations for it a
few days later their assumption comes
true as the Fire Nation led by Commander
Zhao arrives at the northern water tribe
and prepares for their attack while Zhao
focuses on attacking the tribe Zuko
makes his way inside the northern Water
Kingdom and continues his search for the
Avatar in the meantime princess you
leads Aang to a Serene location where he
can meditate once there angry enters the
Avatar State and begins looking for the
Dragon Spirit so that he can get help to
defeat the Fire Nation princess you and
Soka depart to check the situation
outside while Katara opts to remain with
Aang to ensure his safety a short while
later Zuko locates the meditation spot
where he engages in a 1 on one
confrontation with Katara although she
manages to neutralize several of his
fire attacks Katara ultimately gets
defeated by Zuko who then captures Aang
in the spirit world Aang manages to find
the Dragon Spirit who advises him to use
the ocean and show the Fire Nation the
power of water armed with this guidance
as if he didn't already know that fire
is weak to water Aang returns to his
physical body only to find Zuko standing
before him they immediately engage in a
fierce battle with Aang using his
airbending power while the prince uses
his fire bending power the battle rages
on until Katara intervenes freezing Zuko
into a solid block of ice following this
they make their way to join the ongoing
conflict outside Commander zhao's troops
launched their assaults creating chaos
among the northern tribe the
waterbenders are trying their best to
stop the fire nation's soldiers but it
is not that easy because of their
overwhelming number amidst this
commotion Commander Zhao and iro make
their way into a sacred cave there the
commander captures the moon Spirit which
is the water Kingdom's sacred entity
without it the people have no powers
whatsoever sensing his Sinister
intentions iro attempts to dissuade him
urging him not to tamper with nature
however Commander Zhao disregards his
advice and kills the moon's Spirit which
causes all the waterbenders to lose
their abilities now the commander
believes that it will become much easier
for them to take over the northern and
southern water tribe enraged by zhao's
sacrilegious act iro Reveals His Mastery
of firebending this scares the commander
and his followers prompting them to run
from the sacred cave following this iro
emphasizes the importance of maintaining
the balance of Nature and suggests that
there may be a way to restore the
ecosystem hearing this princess you
decides to sacrifice herself to revive
the moon Spirit Soca tries to stop her
from doing so but the princess has made
up her mind she gives him a first and
final kiss before sacrificing herself
for the sake of her people moments later
the waterbenders regain their abilities
and continue their defense against the
Fire Nation afterwards Commander Zhao
and Zuko finally come face to face the
two prepare for a final showdown but
just then iro intervenes still enraged
by what happened he asks his nephew to
step aside following this the
waterbenders who were fueled by anger
over the death of their Princess and the
desecration of the moon's Spirit exact
their Vengeance drowning Zhao to his
death despite this the war isn't over
yet as the Fire Nation soldiers continue
their Advance toward the northern water
tribe on their ships Aang takes a moment
to reflect on his past life before being
trapped in the iceberg thinking about
his upbringing among the air Nomads he
then Taps into the Avatar State one last
time and uses his immense power to raise
the ocean into an enormous barrier
forcing the remaining Fire Nation
soldiers to move back this prompts the
Fire Nation to retreat temporarily
bringing an end to the war in the
aftermath of this event Aang is
presented before the gathered crowd who
pay their respects by bowing to him
can't believe you ended the war with a
single cheap special effect sir in the
final scene we see Zuko's father Fire
Lord ozai who assigns his daughter
princess Azula the task of preventing
the avatar from mastering Earth and fire
will there be a sequel no subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching